in the river there you see this ironic
office in their father drowned their
pools the way we're carrying on they're
going to no longer be around my
grandchildren won't see the right is the
extinction of animal and these people
don't think about like that where they
think about it's good money
we went stop after we win this war the
war on rhino poachers just got tougher
those fighting to save the animal now
have hunting dogs it's eight one zero
five the guy who's underground following
the tracks
they can call in air power when they
spot a poacher's spore or footprint and
the newly formed Rapid Response Unit is
tracking the poachers 24/7
you can see where that aircraft is now
landing they putting up sniper groups
deployments
we were given exclusive access to the
anti poaching teams in the Kruger South
Africa's largest national park it's a
massive area of land it's up to us to
police it sometimes it's a daunting task
and yes you do get this one that's
specially if you come upon caucuses on a
daily basis but we won't stop I meant
well carry on until we witness walk they
have two new helicopters which means
they doubled their air power but they're
trying to protect rhinos in an area the
size of Israel this is a site that may
disappear in the years to come because
the way we're carrying on they're going
to no longer be around and that's what
motivates these people to go out day and
night 24 hours a day to try to protect
them the vultures are the first to alert
us to another slaughter
there's no sentiment in the African bush
the latest dead rhino is a feast for
parasites this is now a crime scene and
the investigators go to work finding
clues they're searching for the bullet
used to kill the Rhino the frequency
that it's happening at and it just not
stopping
it's the extinction of an animal and
these people don't think about like that
they think about it's quick money you
don't think about in the long haul that
this animals gonna be extinct there's
not going to be any more of them
normally with the heavy caliber
ammunition you will find the bullet just
below the skin on this site but there's
nothing so I need to like the skin off
check for damage or trauma below the
skin broken ribs if nothing then we'll
have to dig deeper it's evidence and can
be used in quotes so it's good if you
find something and we must send this
back it's a bullet evidence back we send
it to forensics in Pretoria it's not
nice and I don't want to tell my
grandchildren that you were right I want
to show them to him so yeah it's
disturbing
there are worse sights waiting for the
anti poaching unit like this one the
Rhinos still alive days after his horn
has been hacked off just clinging to
life or this creature the poachers
failed to get his horn
but slashed at his hind legs before he
escaped he had to be killed
anyway to put him out of his pain so the
hunting for the hunters has gone up a
notch
this sadly is just a training exercise
the RS have gone up but so has the
poaching in the Kruger by nearly 30
percent they have more dog units more
boots on the ground
and they're developing and honing skills
aimed at striking fear into the soul of
any poacher it helped us a lot
attacking one man it's like attacking a
one man with three guys when I'm with my
dog so it helps a lot but there's simply
not enough of them
Trek
see them
24 hours after were with investigators
at one Rhino carcass Rangers have
radioed in and fly a white flag to
signal they've spotted another
they can shoot drive along the fence
if you look at just this other side
see a person with kettle
under the tree now that if you can see
them day
well that could be a star I'm saying it
is
and that but you know coming in super
it's a very big
got some people
a lot of poverty said
they are recruited by people who
you know and they can't
the money so big that detective
we joined the Rangers who've spotted the
fresh carcass on the ground the poachers
operate in armed groups usually in
threes and they're well equipped so you
must keep quite always all the time in
the park at the moment there's something
like 15 poaching groups operating they
know that and all the time every time
they don't find one there's a
possibility of another animal being
slaughtered my phone are on a track now
it's got a bit of blood on it
then we know let's follow it has it been
shot and wounded or has it been gored by
another animal so these are the kind of
things you got to follow up day in and
day out and with heat like this I think
me sitting at 41 degrees it's not easy
on the gas
the crisis has led to some tough
decisions is this under anaesthetic no
so this it's a normal run anesthesia
that's why we give you the oxygen as
well no major issues at all they're
moving part of their Rhino family out of
the national park altogether these are
the links they're having to go to to
save the road all because of its horn
because someone wants to pay the price
for what is effectively the same as a
finger nail just made out of keratin but
because of that they're now taking
extreme lengths to save the creature
it's been bought by a private buyer
tranquilized and now going to be taken
to safety on a private Safari farm the
Rhinos partially revived it weighs about
one and a half tons so it has to be able
to walk itself sleepily
and blindfolded to lessen the trauma
into the crate which will take it to its
new home
those killed leave behind young which
often also need to be rescued their
relative lightweight means they can be
airlifted baby rhinos like winter left
orphaned by poachers are especially
vulnerable in the wild his ears were
savaged by hyenas another Rhino named
man G by his saviors had his eyes
slashed by poachers with the same
machete they used to kill his mother
both animals were brought here we're not
saying exactly where in South Africa for
their protection okay so this about a
hundred kilograms between these two this
one is three months oh no father no
winters now fully recovered entirely
unbothered by his lack of ears a mangie
squashed in the middle of two other
orphans here has barely a scar left from
his deep cut although his sight is badly
affected and he'll need future
operations the squealing you hear is
them asking for more milk they like all
the orphans brought here are cared for
day and night by an army of volunteers
who nurse them back to health and whose
contributions fund the center set up by
petronella vote man she was about two
weeks old wind I killed his mom and
attacked him acting with a machete and
didn't do well at all Alex yeah we
struggled with him because of the blood
loss and the trauma and I the injury on
the I was really a big big big problem
because remember the skin on her head
keeps on opening you know it's
stretching and we were very afraid that
he will lose his eye in
enough that ice fine but his other eye
that I got a puncture wound on the
cornea and and it looks like that will
be with him his whole life
hey they couldn't do it without the
volunteers really couldn't because
obviously seen so many rhinos and now
all the rhinos the orphans that come to
through Kruger and so that's every Rhino
of the most of them come from Kruger
Park because that's the biggest sort of
reserve round and if we didn't have them
that really is the future Allen because
that's just the majority of everything
we look after them in every aspect we're
at two o'clock you know doing night
beads so we have to be there I really
really don't want to see the Rhinos
being extinct I think they're you know
incredible I just I love them so much
and I think it'd be such a shame to see
them lost see but this behavior it's
great behavior look they're running and
flying and showing off and I love it in
a very short time under constant care
there's a world of difference in the
cars standing it man
they've got back their spirits no longer
are they traumatized
it's all we know they will be out of
Reiner so every single Rhino there is we
need to dry and safe it was still a long
long way from achieving that Alex
Crawford Sky News South Africa